so this one for for the both of you you
know so a founder has decided to you
know go out and start looking for VC
funding like what do you think actually
that a founder should know or should
really think about before before doing
so yeah I mean I think to my point
earlier do you want to do you want to be
in business with this person you also
have to go in knowing that you know when
VCS are setting your terms they are the
terms that you're gonna raise that round
on there their goal is a percentage
they're not looking at your company and
saying you know doing a simple formula
of oh let's do 10x revenue or whatever
you have in your head they're gonna say
I want 10 to 20 percent and this is how
much we're going to put in so this is
what your valuation is so it's you know
going in knowing that that you know
you're not you you don't get to decide
your valuation you can certainly turn
down a term sheet but it's not it's not
in your control and that in that case
you know what your company is going to
be valued at and I think also you should
know that when you put a VC on your cap
table there is going to be some pressure
and expectations set by those VCS
you know you you're still you know the
founders are still the founders but if
your growth is not at the rate the VC
wants to see they're going to let you
know and they might even you know maybe
a year to three years down the road they
might even suggest well you're you know
that's the CEO you're just not cutting
it anymore we're gonna bring someone
else in
yeah so it's it's it's a it's important
to know this is a business relationship
and the goal is for them to make money
an extraordinary outcome and an
extraordinary outcome and so they're
going to do everything they can they are
capitalists they're going to do
everything they can
yeah it's important I think for people
to understand this that it's it's jet
fuel mmm it is not coal they're not
putting a couple of lumps in coal and
saying let's heat the house for the next
day they're saying let's put you on the
tip of the rocket and let's fill the
rocket with jet fuel and then press the
button that ignites it and try to get
escape velocity and so you're gonna pull
some G's getting into space it is an
unnatural act to
venture capital we started out saying
this is 99 plus percent of businesses
are not venture funded businesses nor
should they be and if you choose to do
the jet fuel you have to be very
comfortable that the person you're gonna
have on that rocket ship with you the VC
is somebody you want to work for for 10
years and that you're willing to do the
incredibly unnatural task of having
non-organic growth some portion of your
growth will be organic but they want the
growth to be not organic they want it to
be super human which means they're
giving you millions of dollars and
they're not giving you that to gain
interest on it I remember when I first
time I raised money I'm like what am I
supposed to do with this couple of
million dollars should I put it in
stocks or mutual funds for bonds and
they're just like Jason we don't we
didn't give you the money to be a bond
manager build your company put in your
bank account we don't care if you're
getting interest on it or not right and
I had to like think that through and
then at one point we had over 10 million
dollars from our bank again so I was
like okay put this percentage of it in
bonds and I remember I was like wow
we're getting like 600,000 the bonds
were doing incredible we got six hundred
thousand dollars in interest on our
bonds it was actually like a meaningful
amount on our burn every month it was
like a third of our burn was being paid
for by the bond revenue well that's kind
of cool right that is not the standard
case and you are going to the the VC's
on Sand Hill Road here in Silicon Valley
and all the advice we have here is from
Silicon Valley we can't speak to China
India Europe in China I actually can't
speak true might be double the
valuations but you might also be doing
personal guarantees in Europe it's gonna
be half the valuations outside of
Silicon Valley it's gonna be somewhere
between half and two-thirds of the
valuation I think here it's a good rule
of thumb but they're gonna want to own
20% so we know that so when you're in
when you're an entrepreneur and let's
say you have that million in revenue two
million in revenue run rate and your
qualifying you're in the running for a
venture around your picking who the
percentage has already been picked it's
gonna be 25% let's say we're 20% we make
it easy for math so now it's who are you
gonna give 20% to and for how much so
how much and then there's turn
the terms you want to go standard so we
can kind of put that aside you want
standard terms and so does the VC she
wants tender terms now you're picking
who and then how much money well if
you've got too many revenues and they're
gonna put it and they're gonna want
twenty percent and you want a ten
million or fifteen or twenty million
dollar valuation you can just do the
back of their mouth it's gonna be two
million or three million or four million
and just get comfortable that and know
it when you're going out
is it when's it too soon time to go out
to talk to VCS if a VC wants to meet
with you should you just take the
meeting is there any downside to doing
that yeah so I think one piece would be
you know it's a distraction from you
know if if you're not fundraising and
that is not the focus at the moment it
is potentially distracting you know it's
taking away from from the core business
you also want to try to understand the
motivation of that VC you know are they
you know looking at a whole category and
planning on investing in perhaps one
company but want to fish out some
information from from you that means an
associate emailed your notes like hey
inside.com
we're really interested in email
newsletters but they're actually looking
at the skim and Axios and we're just the
third place in that race and they just
want to get information from you just
the props perhaps they want to benchmark
some metrics so they can understand you
know how how does how do how do they
compare should I do that
should I go there and give them my
metrics if an associate is emailing me
how do you manage that yeah I think the
in general the answer would be no to be
protective of that sort of information
but I think I think certain founders may
find that transparency has its benefits
you know I think buffer is a really
interesting example of this wrap yeah
buffer app so you can actually just
google buffer metrics and you can see
how much revenue do they make on a daily
basis what does their arr and so there
is no churn they just make sure yeah
their metrics out there laid bare yeah
and he says he gets like ten investors a
day calling yeah hilarious yeah so you
know that that's I would say not the
norm for sure I think in general you
know
we talked about this as well you know
it's a zero-sum game and so you have to
be have to be careful so if investor
ultimately invests in in a competitor
that means that's less money potentially
for you so you know not trying to give a
VC fuel to ultimately invest in somebody
else by matrix I got a lot of these
analyst calls after Sequoia had invested
and inside back in the day was I'd say
we're not fundraising right now but if
you are in Santa Monica and you want to
come by for a cup of coffee let me know
so it's kind of great I'm like oh can we
jump on a call and I'd say we don't have
time for calls but if you're in Santa
Monica and you want to go for a walk
have a cup of coffee and meet the team
we're happy to do that and I say oh look
I was wondering how the N I just say
yeah we're in Santa Monica if you find
yourself in Santa Monica I just repeat
myself over and over again so if they
come to Santa Monica they're asking you
questions how open are you how do you
know how do you yeah you know you know
tell me tell me Jason like tell me about
the five newest newsletters you know how
many how many subscribers are you add
what are you seeing in open rates yeah
so information that is publicly
available I would just put out there and
then you have two choices when you have
information that you don't want out
there you could say well that's a little
bit of our secret sauce we don't really
want that information out there we don't
share that information outside of our
board or you can say oh well that's what
I used to do I would give sometimes a
little bit of the opposite information
if something is going very well I'd say
we're figuring that out we haven't
figured that out yet
well what about you know you were saying
like how do they grow or something what
are your tips and tricks for growing
these things sure and I would you say
something like end of the day it's about
quality you can do all kinds of the
standard tricks that you find on media
more growth hacking newsletters or blogs
all that stuff could possibly work it's
really at the end of the day about
quality it's what you put on the plate
that's what makes the restaurant
successful now that may not be in fact
the case so I would just be a little bit
sort of filibustering like a
presidential candidate in a debate
I would filibuster a bit and and or just
tell him straight up like yeah we we
have a secret strategy that we do we
don't share that playbook but yeah we
have a playbook for that and then you
have to also know who you're dealing
with so if it's an associate sometimes
associates can have a lot of influence
sure and other times they could be doing
what you're
which is just collecting data and their
boss is saying just get me the churn
rates of the top ten SAS companies I
want to make a chart and put slack on
that chart against Yammer and Salesforce
and you know how quickly is it growing
or something like that I don't think you
want to participate in those kind of
things and I don't think you want to
you're not on an obligation under an
obligation to get on the phone I just
had actually a journalist like the
organization one of the journalism
organizations like a very well-known one
was like hey we're doing a report on
email newsletters we're hoping to talk
to you because insides a leader in that
category and I was like yeah thanks I'm
on deadline for my book right now I
can't talk there well it's very simple
it's gotta answer like five six
questions and I'm like we're you know
we're really not interested in educating
the more I've decided the person I said
can delay we're not interested in
educating the market how what the
opportunity is I think will be good for
you and I was like yeah we're gonna pass
for now I just said that every man we're
gonna pass for now thank you for the
opportunity you're not a United
obligation to even reply so a lot of
times people email me like can you tell
me when Hoover's going public or you
know it's Travis is gonna be yeah
exactly
or can you tell me what you know is
Travis coming back to the good be CEO or
something you know and I'm and I just
don't even reply where I have a standard
thing that I cut and paste that says I
don't speak for my company's the CEOs do